[Applause]
hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remembered so you don't have to the new
Looney tune show good or bad there's
been a lot of variations of the classic
Looney Tunes characters over the years
but this latest reincarnation has caused
the most controversy and when I say
controversy I mean keeps complaining
about on message boards this prank you
bought there that to make videos about
it with that said this rendition seems
to have the most audiences split the
reason mostly centering around the
Looney Tunes being domesticated they're
not loony anymore as some say it's
mostly dialogue with not enough
slapstick and too many changes made to
the Looney Tunes personas being a
die-hard Looney Tunes fan myself I felt
it only fair to throw in my two cents
and in my opinion I think it's funny
undeniably flawed but still very funny I
personally enjoy it because the focus is
kept out what made the Looney Tunes
hilarious to begin with the Looney Tunes
personalities people forget that a lot
of the Looney Tunes cartoons didn't have
as much slapstick as you would think it
actually was a lot of talking take the
most famous examples with Elmer bugs and
Daffy most of it technically is just
standing around discussing who the
slapstick should happen to and only once
in a while did the slapstick actually
happen this is why many say the Warner
Brothers cartoons were more adult humor
where Disney cartoons were more childish
humor there's definitely had more motion
and action but focus less on developing
the jokes now keep in mind also that
these original cartoons were usually
about 7 minutes long TV shows nowadays
are at least triple that time so
everything has to be expanded including
the dialogue and with that said the
slapstick is still there it just has to
be proportionate to the time given or
else it'll be overused but that's not
the only complaint another one is that
they're too domesticated bugs and Daffy
live in suburbia and focused more on the
problems that Seinfeld episode would
focus on rather than a Looney tune short
well in many respects I think cyfle is
kind of similar to looney tunes isn't
Jerry very similar to bugs or George
very similar to Daffy hell even the
visual humor and hairbrained schemes of
Kramer seem very similar to the coyote
so I think it's a very welcomed
comparison
and in many respects Looney Tunes
actually has a bigger advantage because
it's animated therefore it can go even
further with its humor
for example there's an episode where
Lola invites bugs to be in her family
portrait
but when bugs chips a tooth she wants to
selfishly leave him out
despite bugs being more determined than
ever to now want to be in it just out of
spite
now that very Seinfeld but the fact that
they go so far as to have a car chase
with the coach and carriage and
explosion and a fall off a cliff
resulting in all of them getting a
chipped tooth for the portrait that's
Looney Tunes so many respects it is a
similar setup but they can have even
more fun and creativity with their jokes
because simply put there's no boundaries
I guess another reason it works for me
is because I believe that while truly
great characters don't change over time
environments do and if Looney Tunes
still wants to speak to both an adult
and a kid audience the characters can
stay the same but it has to evolve with
the rest of the world changes have to be
made and I think many of us know how
most people react to change nowadays but
as long as the environments create
comedic possibilities for their
personalities to work off of I'm all for
it it's true some of the characters have
been changed around but again I think
it's for the better
bugs is just as much the everyman now as
he was in the past because the show
acknowledges people's weaknesses of
modern day and they're clever solutions
of modern day by having him more fragile
and actually able to lose it makes him
more identifiable as well as much more
appreciative when he actually does win
if he always won it would become boring
even the original cartoons had to mix it
up once in a while and bugs always had
to show some weakness as he had to get
into a predicament that he had to get
out of plus we're all the more
interested and how he'll use his cool
and wit to deal with the situation when
we know it can just as easily backfire
Daffy is still just as selfish and
diabolical as ever porky still seems to
be the optimistic pawn and everybody's
plan and then we have Lola oh jesus
sweet hippity hoppity Christ
thank you for Lola
this has literally gone from one of my
most despised lily tune characters into
one of my favorites that's kristin wiig
of bridesmaids fame doing the voice and
they transformed her from a bland
sexualized token chick into a crazy
absent-minded often unfocused goofball
living only in the bubbly madness of her
mind and I know some of you are thinking
oh but that's not the original Lola
character cuz oh yeah there was a ton to
work with like bunny boobies the fact
that she didn't like to be called doll
don't be more than that yeah her
luminous if any came from how other
people reacted to the character not from
the character herself it was them going
oh she sexualized
and that's it this is an actual
personality that can work off of the
other personalities in the show granted
she still has the bunny boobies which is
a little weird but what's the characters
creative with them yeah I guess it would
send the pervs into overtime but they
just had to walk around with no clothes
like the others they also do well at
balancing out other characters so that
they can still seem likable half of what
Daffy gets away with is helped by the
fact that he has a no-nonsense
girlfriend named Tina who constantly
keeps him in check she's not as goofy as
the other characters but she still has a
definite personality and is meant to be
more grounded similar to how a character
like porky is but now with that said
there are some changes that inevitably
I'm not gonna agree with either like
making the Tasmanian Devil their dog is
kind of lame especially when I think
there actually could be some real
comedic possibilities from him witch
hazel being a sassy black woman is
really odd come on she was fine the way
she was
and those little music videos in between
well funny sometimes can get a little
too repetitive I'm glad they only do
them now when they feel like it and
don't force themselves to do one every
episode but let's get down to the final
major complaint when the jokes just
aren't funny yeah that can be a major
problem no as I said before I think most
of the jokes in the show work but when
they die man
they really die like they have a
lot of good writers working on it then
like maybe one jackass who just keeps
throwing in terrible jokes there's also
some times where the stories are so
ingeniously tied together but then they
never add up to a strong payoff there's
an episode for example dealing with
father figures three separate stories
are going on that actually all come
together in the very end and it
hilariously just keeps building and
building you think it's gonna work its
way up to a big climax but instead it's
just sort of a weak bit of slapstick and
that's it
so in a sense when people say they don't
like the show I know where they're
coming from there are times where the
show really loses focus it's really
tough to stomach in I'm not going to
pretend like it's not but when it hits
bull's eyes I truly feel it captures the
spirit of the Looney Tunes almost as
much as the original because it puts the
same recognizable characters in brand
new scenarios that makes way for brand
new possibilities and that's what the
Looney Tunes always were to me and the
reason that gets so confused about some
fans shouting sellout is that they never
seem to get angry at the past obvious
sellouts so let me get this straight
guys free glutamates let's go our way
heard of the schoolgirl
I know I've been there but the Looney
Tunes are dead I'm sorry water brothers
you flew too close to some renditions I
did include because they got the proper
response they desert
loonatics unleashed was despised and
back in action got overwhelming reaction
of but people still seem split about the
new animated series diehard split if you
don't like it because you feel there
aren't enough funny jokes and sometimes
it goes a little too far and not far
enough I understand and completely
sympathize with your judgement but if
you're just gonna hate because something
is different I kindly ask that you go to
that corner of the internet that
remembers your utopian time period that
never existed if you're like me or
easily both the good and the bad with
the show I want me to point out the top
10 best episode so you can avoid the
duds father figures Lola's father wants
to connect to the closest thing to a son
he's ever had it's funny clever and even
touching at times even if it's ending is
underwhelming to bowl or not to bowl
Daffy joins a bowling team but has to be
told that he's the only bad player in
the middle of a big tournament this
ending will have you laughing for hours
eligible bachelors bugs and Lola ticket
Tour de France well Brandi gives it to
her divorce with a story about how she
was a kick-ass spy of World War two
that's actually kind of gripping at
times but float this might be Daffy at
his cruelest and it's fascinating to see
just how despicable we can take this
character before we want to kill him
some might see it as going too far but I
think it's pretty damn funny numbers
only the first appearance of Lola adds
the perfect introduction again has sort
of a weak ending but it's still a Lola
centered episode and to me those rarely
failed double
Debbie wants to impress his new
girlfriend Tina so he has Lola for
advice not realizing Lola falls for her
own techniques and becomes obsessed with
Daffy herself another great stalker
episode from our favorite crazy
you've got hate mail Debbie learns from
Tina that he can let off steam by
writing an angry email and then deleting
it
so Daffy writes an angry email to
everybody he knows but accidentally
sends it out the reactions are mostly
why do you think this one has lots of
lats of surprisingly warm ending and
maybe the funniest design of Yosemite
Sam you'll ever see I won't ruin it for
you here but it's worth checking out
rebel without a glove bugs loses his
trademark glove so he wears a pair of
biker gloves instead altering his entire
personality as well as scaring the crap
out of the people around him this is not
only as funny as it sounds but we also
get some fascinating insight into
Debbie's psyche for example what is the
story with that white thing on his neck
again I won't give away the answer
the DMV what can I say they do every
hilarious joke you could do with these
characters being at the most miserable
place on earth the comedy writes itself
and most of them hit head-on and my
personal favorite episode is one called
customer service this plays into our
fears that a customer service agent
played by a devilishly evil sessile
turtle are actually satyrs who love to
torture their clients by putting them on
hold or somehow creating more problems
it's a return to form for bugs as he
dons disguises and plans diabolical
schemes all in the name of sweet revenge
the jokes are funny the setup is great
the subplots entertaining they all tied
together and it's a perfect mix of the
Looney Tunes combined with modern-day
problems but what the hell do I know
check out the show and see for yourself
check it out pick a side and see what
you've been missing or glad you've been
missing I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to
[Music]
you